will you ever return to Magic didn't she
do magic as a kid did you not study
under the great
sliding sliding he did you are so funny
you you used to yeah
I'm not making a joke well Steve Martin
had the great fly Deanie but when he did
have flights yeah I bet he based it on
sliding of course because he was a magic
how did you get to study with the great
sliding my dad somehow found because
okay there was a place called Lieutenant
magic shop right how old are you when
you went into magic I was probably like
11 or 12. a lot of comedians do this
yeah
um and this place Louis 10 and magic in
Times Square on the 8th floor ninth
floor this I think it was like the brill
building or one of those buildings and
you go in there and they would um demo
all the tricks for you these you know
out of work magician guys who work there
right and they were awesome and you
could buy the tricks and that's it you
know and I think I I my dad took me
there and he said my son wants to take
magic uh lessons and right because I had
the Tarbell person magic that you could
send away and everything you do you take
very seriously for about five minutes
and so yeah so I went and uh he found
that they recommended slidini who lived
in a railroad flat on uh
make sure you don't want to go into
magic when you see the outcome you're
living in a railroad but he was
brilliant right brilliant and yeah and
he had this this signature trick where
that he would just take somebody from
the audience sit him down from and he'd
take some kleenex and he would make the
kleenex disappear in front of their face
did slidini teach you this trick yes he
did but did I tell you about this before
no okay so he the the point of it was
that the audience would be like say to
the right he had the person in front of
him and so he would be making it
disappear and the person would be like
oh my God but the audience would be
watching what he was doing which was
taking the the handkerchief or the the
um Kleenex and flipping it over the
person's head behind them this like
sleight of hand move right and so I he
taught me that trick that I would
practice on my system yes and did you
perfect it I did never perfected it I
would attempt it on her multiple times
here's a here's a uh you can do that I
haven't tried it for a while here's a
tissue how many tissues do you need let
me see um I really haven't tried this
world you don't take off your headphones
yeah I mean it was basically I haven't
tried it
I used to scare my sister because I'm
afraid you're gonna poke me I get too
close to her and she's like are you
gonna do that trick or you almost hit me
in the face yeah don't hit me so it'd be
like he'd take this and you go like this
and you go like this that's the trick
yeah I could do that I should do that
with my kids
when it's done well it's brilliant what
was your magic name the great stellini
no there was no great no it didn't it
didn't last that long the magic phase